All right, let's talk about it, shall we?
Nine times out of 10,
when you're scrolling TikTok,
you see people who look like me.
Why am I using this video to say that?
Well, it just so happens
that a lot of creators are speaking out for TikTok.
Silencing by pocket
Indigenous creators.
We all know it's true.
Don't. Don't try.
And because of my hashtags,
this one might get shadow banned, too.
But here's what I need you to do.
I tagged the real bipoc creator that created this video
before this palm skinned person went and stole it
word for word.
What we should be doing
is doing a coin band for our bipoc,
an indigenous community,
or even tagging them when we use a sound of theirs.
We shall not be using word for word
their content without their permission. Okay?